terry who is going to speak about uh
no quantum speed up over gradient listen
for non-smooth convex optimization
and the flow is your turn
um thanks thanks andres thanks to the
organizers for inviting me
um all right so i'm going to talk about
can quantum computers speed up gradient
descent
please feel free to ask questions during
or
after the talk and this is joint work
with
ankit who's a researcher at microsoft
research india pranith
who was a researcher at microsoft
research india while this work was done
and now is google research and suhil
was an intern at microsoft research and
is a phd student at
the tata institute of fundamental
research
okay so let's let's start with some
motivation
um so the first couple of slides are
just gonna be a little story about um
you know why you might care about this
problem but on slide four or so i'll
just state the formal problem if you
don't care about the story
you can pick up again there so what's
going on here is
we're interested in gradient design
gradient descent is this
algorithm for minimizing functions in rn
so you have a multivariated function
takes an n variable splits out one real
number
and you want to minimize this function
over some domain and it's a very popular
algorithm
in practice and it's used both as a
heuristic so we
cannot prove provable convergence
guarantees so for example for training
neural networks
it's used all over the place in machine
learning and it's also approved in
settings where you can prove stuff
such as in convex optimization and my
talk's going to be about this ladder
setting about convex optimization
and the algorithm is very simple in fact
i think the algorithm was
proposed in um 1847
so a very long time ago and uh
yeah so let me just explain what the
algorithm is with a very simple picture
so you're trying to minimize a function
so let's take a univariate function so
y equals f of x and let's say you start
at this point x zero and you're trying
to minimize the function
you have only two directions to go in
left or right and which direction should
you go in
well you can compute the derivative at
that point x zero and
you should go in the direction of of the
descending direction it kind of seems
obvious like why would you go left
and you know you take a step in that
direction and you get to this point x1
and you do the same thing and it
in this picture at least it's clear that
you'll get to the minimum or you'll get
to a minimum
and this is just the this is the idea of
gradient descent so
of course it's also one variable example
but in the multivariable case you
compute the gradient at a point
and take one step in the negative
direction of the gradient
so like very formally this is what the
algorithm
iteration step looks like if you're at
point
x i you compute the gradient at point x
i
and take a small step in the direction
of minus the gradient and the step size
is eta this is a parameter you have to
choose
and uh yeah for completeness the
gradient of a function at
a point x is defined as this thing it's
the
vector of partial derivatives in each of
the directions
technically the function needs to be
differentiable for this but
you can actually get around this and
i'll say something about this later
okay so that's that's just what gradient
descent does that's the great that's the
basic gradient descent algorithm
okay very intuitive very popular
cool okay so let me ask the question
can quantum computers speed up this
algorithm right this algorithm is very
popular so it would be great if we can
speed this up
and immediately if you think about this
for a little while um you're met with
the question well what does this really
mean right
what does what does it mean for a
quantum computer to speed up an
algorithm
right so for example does shore's
algorithm speed up the best
classical algorithm for for factoring
uh it's it's again probably probably not
like
these algorithms look nothing alike like
the best classical algorithm for
factoring doesn't look like shore's
algorithm
in general it's not totally clear what
it means for to to say
can you speed up gradient descender can
you speed up a particular algorithm
you could try to formalize this question
some not very helpful ways so
here's one formalization that i don't
like which is where you would say that
the quantum algorithm that speeds up
gradient descent
should do basically exactly what
gradient descent does it should output
the same sequence of points
x0 x1 x2 and so on that gradient descent
would have had you run gradient descent
on your input
but this is this is too much right like
you're asking the quantum algorithm to
do too much
so that's not that's not a great way to
formalize the question
but what is meaningful is to say that
you can fix some problem
say problem x and say quantum computer
solve this problem faster than
gradient design solves the problem
and so what we do is we choose to
formalize the questions
as follows we say consider some problem
that can be solved by grading descent
and furthermore this is really important
a problem for its gradient descent is
the optimal classical algorithm
because otherwise even classical
algorithms could do better than gradient
distance somewhere you want a problem
that is
that truly captures the power of
gradient descent it's a problem for
which
gradient descent is the best classical
algorithm to run and then
we can ask can quantum compute to solve
this problem faster so there's just one
way of formalizing the problem
you could there could be others but this
is just
this is our story to motivate this
problem and as i'll show you in the next
in a couple slides though the problem is
just very natural so even if you don't
buy the story
the is independently well motivated
okay so let's let me let me tell you
what this problem is so to tell you what
this problem is i just have to give you
a brief intro to convex optimization
so converse optimization is this field
you know studies optimization problems
of a special type where you're trying to
minimize a convex function over a convex
set
and most people probably know what these
things mean but
it's just a couple of pictures showing
what a convex function is a convex
function is a function
where if you draw a line segment between
two points on the
on the function the line segment lies
above the function so here's some
examples of functions that are and are
not convex
and a convex set is a set where if you
take a line segment in the set then
every point on the line segment is also
in the set
okay and in this problem i'm going to
choose a very simple
convex set so i'm just going to choose
the the ball of radius r around the
origin
it's probably like the simplest set you
can think of
that's convex and we're just going to
try to minimize a function
f over this ball
so if you just want to if you want to do
this you need to know a little more
about the function um
in particular the complexity of the
problem will depend on how how quickly
the function can change in a small
small interval so you know the function
changes an arbitrarily large amount in
arbitrarily small interval
then you're not going to be able to find
a minimum so we need some guarantee
about how quickly it changes
and the standard way to ask for such a
guarantee is to ask for the function to
be lip sheds
and what that means is there's some
constant g
for which this relationship holds with
this relationship just expresses the
fact that if you
if you move a certain amount in the
domain then you don't move more than g
times that amount
in the range
okay so now that i've defined this i can
say what our basic problem is our
problem is
um constrained convex optimization so
you have a constraint set which is the
ball of radius r
you have some function which is
lipschitz with lipschitz constant g
and x star is the true minimizer it's
the point
inside the unit inside the ball of
radius r where the function
f achieves its minimum value and you
don't need to find x star exactly you
just need to find an epsilon
approximation so
it's fine if you output some other point
x the only the guarantee
requires that f of x minus f of x star
is less than epsilon
okay so that's the that's the basic
problem we're going to be considering in
this talk
are are there any questions at this
point or should i
uh there is a question of question robin
by
if not what does it mean that gradient
decision can solve a problem optimally
in general
corner explanation it's not very clear
what it means to solve a problem
optimally
as we always find out approximate
solutions
and runtime depends on approximation
guarantees
okay yeah that's a great question so
i'll say
i'll say in a couple slides exactly what
i mean but so formally the problem
will have a bunch of parameters like you
know delicious constant and the radius r
and epsilon
and the dimension and what i'll mean by
optimal
is i'll mean optimal dependence on all
of these parameters
but i need to formalize the problem a
little more before i can explain what
that means
okay so yes let's let's go to the next
slide okay so i need to
formalize this problem and what's the
part of the problem that needs
formalization is i haven't told you how
the input is represented so for a
computational problem
this is very important like the
complexity of the problem will often
depend on how the input is represented
and
what i'm going to do here is i'm going
to talk about a black box
representation and what this means is
you have
let's start with what's called a zeroth
order convex optimization here you have
a black box that can compute the
function f for you on any input of your
choice
this is not the setting we're working in
because gradient descent doesn't
just use the function value it also
needs the gradient so this is called
first
order black box convex optimization so
here you have access to both the
function and the gradient
of the function which means you can
submit to this black box and input x
and ask the black box for either f x or
grad f of x
um or maybe this is a good point to say
that if the function is not
differentiable technically the great you
know the gradient may not exist but what
you want is
something called the subgradient and
i'll say a little bit about it later but
for now to understand the problem just
just think of it as the gradient and
it's
it's totally fine and the phrase black
box refers to the fact that
you can only query this this box at
inputs of your choice you don't actually
know anything about the function other
than
this query access to this black box so
you don't know what the function looks
like or
you don't have some global structural
understanding of f other than our
assumption
which is that it's g elixirs
okay now that i've specified the problem
the input formally
i can now tell you the the formal
version of this problem so it's first
order black box convex optimization so
the same setting as before
the same same parameters as before and
the goal
is to solve this problem while
minimizing the number of evaluations of
f and grada or number of queries to this
black box
now that's the formal way of saying what
we're trying to do
okay good and
right so now i can get to exactly what i
mean by optimal
so th this problem depends on four
parameters right
uh four parameters appear in this
problem ng r and epsilon
but they're not all independent
parameters actually there's only two
parameters n
and g are over epsilon and the reason
there's only two parameters is there's
some freedom in the problem
which is you can scale the input and
output domains
and this doesn't really affect the
problem so
you can you can you can play around with
these two parameters gr and epsilon and
trade them off against each other so
really it's just one parameter gr over
epsilon or in other words you can just
fix g and r to be one with our loss of
generality and just think of the
being two parameters n and epsilon
okay so there's two parameters and
epsilon basically and now you can ask
what are the best
classical algorithms for this problem
and it turns out there's
two different best classical algorithms
and one is gradient descent which has
complexity gr over epsilon squared
and this is the kind of algorithms i'm
going to be talking about today and
these are called dimension independent
algorithms because you
if as you notice the dimension n doesn't
appear in the complexity
whereas the this other class of
algorithms which are dimension dependent
algorithms
um and does appear in the complexity but
i'm not really going to talk about those
algorithms but i'm just mentioning it
now because
people often ask um about you know
because they're familiar with the
ellipsoid algorithm how does that work
but i'm kind of thinking of the
situation where n is very large so you
don't want dependence on n
and in this case it turns out the
gradient descendancy
is the optimal algorithm and what that
means is you can prove a lower bound
that you need gr or epsilon squared
queries any classical algorithm
must make so many queries okay any
questions at this point
okay good um
right so as i said uh gradient descent
solves this problem that i formally
stated with gr epsilon squared queries
and just to be like super explicit i'll
tell you what what the algorithm is in
this
this scenario um you what you'll do is
you know you're
minimizing over this ball of radius r
you don't know anything about where the
minimum is so you might as well start
the origin which is the center of this
ball
and then you do the following iteration
t times
um you take the point that you're at x i
you compute the gradient of that point
and you subtract eta times the gradient
from your point x i
the the step size eta is chosen to be
epsilon this is your accuracy parameter
and finally this step might take you
outside the ball of radius r
which is which is bad because you're
trying to find the minimum inside the
ball of radius r so then you just
project yourself back to the ball of
radius r
that's something that's right it's very
easy to do
and then finally you just output the
average of
all of your iterative so far so this is
one version of gradient descent that
works and it indeed has
the correctness guarantee which i'm not
going to prove but it's
actually pretty easy to establish the
correctness current is just that the
output of this algorithm is
uh f of x minus f of x star is less than
epsilon
and and furthermore the optimality claim
is the following that any randomized
algorithm that's dimension independent
that solves this problem must make g r
over epsilon squared queries to these
oracles okay good any any questions
um so there's a remark of an issue that
these are
number of iterations right not the
like gradient may need some time to
compute ourselves these are number of
queries made to the oracle's
f and gradif that is the complexity
method number of queries
and can i ask another quick
clarification there
so you claim that the gradient descent
was optimal but isn't the
uh isn't it actually the necessary
momentum as a
method that's optimal uh no no not not
in this setting so in this setting
all i've done is i've assumed that the
function is bounded
uh lipschitz constant and in this case
this this gradient descent algorithm
this specific algorithm that's on this
slide
is the optimal algorithm the setting
that you're thinking of is where you
assume that the function is smooth
like the first derivative is also
bounded and that's when the
nestrom momentum algorithm is optimal
okay thanks yeah any other questions
okay good so yeah so we have this
problem
it's totally formally stated and
gradient descent is optimal for it
and i'm going to ask well what's the
quantum query complexity of this problem
right what's the complexity of solving
this problem on a quantum computer
um now this is my slide about like
what's the issue with gradients let me
let me just skip this it's not it's not
a big deal
essentially what happens is if the
gradient if the function is not
differentiable the gradient may not
exist
and so what you do is you replace the
gradient with this object called the sub
gradient
and the sub gradient is just any vector
that satisfies this this equation that
the gradient satisfies
the sub gradient may not be unique but
if the function's differentiable
the sub gradient always equals the
gradient but
the function the sub gradient always
exists so all you have to do for this
these optimization problems is
assume that the the when you query the
black box with
for the gradient you get a valid sub
gradient
and that's kind of how you make it work
for non-different interval functions but
it's not a big deal if you haven't seen
what sub gradients are before they
everything will make sense if you just
take the intuition of gradients as
for differentiable functions
[Music]
okay so yeah so now we can say we can
ask the question of can quantum computer
speed of gradient descent and as i said
this is how we're going to formalize it
we're going to say this is the
this is the problem we're only counting
the number of queries to f and grad f
uh gradient descent solves this with
some complexity grow epsilon squared
and no classical algorithm even
randomized so note that gradient descent
is a deterministic algorithm
but what i'm claiming is even randomized
algorithms can't solve this problem any
faster
than gradient descent so gradient
descent is optimal among all classical
algorithms
can quantum compute to solve this
problem faster that's the
that's the question and there's one one
last thing that's to be done to make
this question formal
quantumly which is i have to tell you
how quantum algorithms have access to f
and grad f
unfortunately since this is a quantum
workshop i think most people know
what's going to happen over here it's
just the usual thing you take some
classical black box you make it quantum
by making it reversible and unitary
um traditionally it's done in the
setting of boolean functions so you have
some classical black box that takes an
input string x and outputs a bit f of x
this is not reversible or unitary so you
would make it into a quantum
black box and the justification for why
this is reasonable is because if you had
a classical algorithm or a classical
circuit that did the thing on the left
then you can
convert it to a quantum algorithm in a
completely mechanical way
that does the thing on the right and the
gate complexity will be the same it'll
use the same number of gates so
that's why it makes sense so you know we
did the same thing and
there's an additional wrinkle in our
model is that we're dealing with real
numbers
so you have to deal with that but uh
let's let's not worry about it it's not
it's not going to matter at all so let's
let's forget about that but
one way one way to do that is you can
just say that the real numbers are
specified arbitrarily high precision you
can ask for whatever precision you want
from the oracle and it still counts as
one query
all right so now i've made the the the
problem
well defined quantumly and uh
let me go back to would be what are we
trying what are we asking we're asking
can quantum algorithms solve this
problem faster
and we know a classical lower bound of
gr or epsilon squared
so one thing to do when you're at this
kind of a place where
you're trying to ask if quantum
algorithms can solve the problem faster
than classical algorithms is to take the
classical hard instance the the
hard instance that appears in the
classic lower bound and see if you can
speed that up quantumly
that's a good that's a good place to
start because you know that that
instance is hard
and so that's what i'm going to do i'm
going to investigate
the classical randomized lower bound
heart instance
and and this is where it looks like uh
as i said before
let's just assume that g and r are one
so there's only one parameter epsilon
and we're working this dimension
independent setting so that means n can
be arbitrarily large so i only need n to
be as large as one or epsilon squared
and i'm going to consider the following
class of functions f z of
f z of x where z is an n bit string of
plus ones and minus ones and the
function is just defined as
the z i x i maxed over all the indices i
and it's not easy it's not it's not hard
to show this is a convex function
because
z i x i are linear functions and the max
of convex functions is convex
and it um yes this function's kind of
interesting
um so it satisfies our assumptions of
course it's
it's one lip [ __ ] we're trying to
minimize it over the unit ball and it
turns out you can figure out what the
um optimal point is very very easily
because what you want is you want to
minimize this function so you want this
this product z i x i to be negative
everywhere so you want x i to have the
opposite sign of z
i and um you have a constraint on the
the norm of x right because you have to
be in the unit ball so you want to
choose the
the furthest away x from the origin that
has this property and it turns out
it's this point and the minimum value is
well this whatever minus one over
n um okay cool and
uh any randomized algorithm that solves
this problem
must make one wrap so that's quite
queries that's that's the claim i'm not
going to prove it but
it's actually not very hard to prove
essentially the intuition is that every
query you make
only reveals one zi to you and you
really need to figure out all the zi's
to define this optimal point
and so you really need to make um
like n ish queries and n is one over
epsilon squared
okay so that's our classical about
and as i motivated like we should
think about uh can we do better on this
family of functions with a quantum
algorithm
that's a good place to start and um
yeah so can we do that uh just a recap
of the previous slide
we have this family of functions max i z
i x i and any randomized algorithm must
make omega n queries can we do better
than n
quantumly okay so to answer this
question let's
um let's just make some observations
about this function first
so here's three very simple observations
in increasing order of complexity
so the first observation is if i query
with the all ones vector
then the response from the oracle for f
like f of x is one if and only if one of
these z i's is one right because now now
f of x just becomes max i
z i and z is a plus minus one string so
it tells me one if and only if there's
an index equal to one
um the second observation is now instead
of the all ones vector if i just take
the all ones vector supported on a set s
the indicator vector of some set
then i'll get back a one if and only if
there exists an index in that set
for which z i equals one and in other
words
we're able to make queries of the
following form i can specify an
arbitrary subset of my choice
and ask the oracle does z the string z
which i'm thinking of an n bit string
contain a plus one within this
specified subset and i'm going to call
this a subset or
query and the reason i call it that is i
specify subset and what the oracle does
it computes the logical or
of all the bits inside that subset where
plus one is treated as
a logical true
okay so now the problem is reduced to
the fact that we have some
end bit string or string a plus minus
one string of length n
and we have these subset or queries to
them and we want to learn all of these
zi so we want to learn the entire string
and can you do that with fewer than n
queries and it turns out that you can
this is a remarkable result of
alexander bellows he shows that
given the subset or queries you can
actually learn all of these zi's with
high probability
using only square root and quantum
queries so in fact
e quantum algorithms can solve this
problem faster and there's a quadratic
speed up
this classical hard family can be solved
faster by quantum algorithms
okay that's cool any any questions about
this so far probably a good place to
pause
nope okay good so right right so
yeah so now we're at a pretty
interesting point right so when when we
this is kind of a chronological story
also how how we
did this research so we also got to this
point at some point in our research and
then we were
we're like so there is a hard family of
functions that appears in the classical
orbit which can be solved quadratically
fast
faster quantumly so what's uh what's
going on right
like can quantum computers always give a
quadratic speed up
or like was just a coincidence
that's kind of like the obvious thing
you would ask at this point
like was this just some special property
of this family of functions or is it
just like a general phenomenon
that quantum computers exhibit
and the main result is that well there
actually there's no there's no quantum
speed up in general there exists a hard
family
just a different heart family of
functions for which even quantum
algorithms must make
one restaurant quite queries which is
the complexity of gradient descent
so this answers the question that we
sought out
um our formalization of this question
which is in the setting of first order
black box convex optimization there's no
quantum speed up over
gradient descent
good okay so now that i still have five
minutes i can tell you a little bit
about how the quantum lower bound works
i don't want to get into too many
details but i'm going to kind of roughly
sketch what's what's the key idea so to
understand what's the key idea is
uh recall the classical lower bound your
function f z of x was a max over i
z i x i um
and this this lower bound instance
doesn't work for quantum algorithm so
we're gonna have to modify it in some
way
so we we modified in two ways so the
first way is
that is the first term which is i have
these inner products of v i and x and
let me explain what's going on over
there so z i x i is just the ith bit of
z
multiplied by the either bit of x but
you can also view this as an inner
product between two vectors in rn
the first vector is x itself and the
other vector is
the ith basis vector multiplied with the
sine
so it's z i e i where e i is the either
basis vector
and so now what's happening is it's a
max over n things and each of these n
things is an inner product of our input
vector x
with one of the one of the basis vectors
with a sign
in front of it so plus or minus a basis
vector and these basis vectors are all
orthogonal to each other
so there's something going on in this
function which privileges the
standard basis the computational basis
because i'm using these
e i's as my vectors so to you know make
the problem more quantum
and make the instance more quantum we we
choose a random
set of orthonormal vectors now so v1 to
vk
are they're still orthonormal they're
just not the basis
standard basis vectors they're just some
random collection of vectors
so that's the first change we make to go
from the classical orbital
so sorry why did you change k to n here
to enter k
uh yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna use fewer
vectors than than the dimension this
time
so because our yeah we don't know how to
make the lower bounds go through with k
equal to n
so i'll use um in other words i'm going
to need a larger dimension n
to prove the same lower bound in the
quantum case than in the classical case
so that's the that's the first change
that we make we make the zi xi become
inner products and the second one is we
add a penalty term
that's proportional to the index i and
so there's a lot of stuff going on the
second term but
just forget about everything there
except the minus i
so what's happening here is you're
taking a maximum of a bunch of things
but the first term gets a minus one the
second term gets a minus two the third
term gets a minus three and so on
so each term is being being penalized in
a different way
and the reason we're doing this uh the
intuition is that if i pick a random
vector x so just pick
x uniformly at random in the unit ball
with this orthonormal set of vectors it
will roughly have the same inner product
the inner product will be roughly one
over square with the dimension
and if all of these vectors have roughly
the same inner product we want to
enforce an ordering on them we want to
say that
if they're all roughly the same then
then because we're penalizing all of the
vectors
much more than we're penalizing the
first vector you should output the first
vector
the the other stuff that's going on over
there this gamma and stuff that's kind
of setting the
size of the penalty so i want the panel
to be penalty to be large enough that
it's it's actually comparable to this
one over square root of the dimension um
variance that that'll happen in these
different
v i x inner products um
yeah that maybe that's all i wanted to
say about how we change the function and
then uh
what's the yeah what's the intuition for
how the lower bound works
is um as i said if you query this
function on a random x
there's a very good chance that the
function is actually maximized on the
first term
so this this is a max of k things you
know v one x v two x v three x and so on
there's a very good chance like a very
good meaning like one minus one over
polynomial
chance that the function is maximized on
the first term so the function looks
like
v one inner product x at the point
you've queried
and so you get this value v1 in a
product x if you create the function and
if you query the gradient what's the
gradient of v one inner product x v one
in a product x is just a linear function
the gradient is v one so you'll learn
the first vector v one
so the intuition is that the first query
only reveals the vector v1 to you
the second query can at best reveal v2
to you
if you if you query it with a random
vector
on the on the space on the whole space
minus v1 so
so now remove v1 from your space and not
pick a random vector
then you'll get v2 and you keep doing
this and you get v3 and so on
and the lower bound idea is that this is
every algorithm
only learns vectors in this order you
must first learn v1 then you learn v2
then you learn v3 and so on
but you must know all k vectors to get
the final answer
so you must make cake queries that's
that's kind of a high level
overview of how this proof works so it's
very analogous actually to the
classical orban at least in terms of
high level ideas
uh making it rigorous is is somewhat
different
quantumly than classically so quantumly
we have to use the hybrid argument
that's that's like the lower bound
workhorse
all right so okay i'm at the end of my
time so let me let me conclude with some
some some open problems
so in one sense the the result is
somewhat disappointing there's no
quantum speed up
in the setting of first starter convex
optimization uh but there is a speed up
over this very special class of
functions the one the ones that appear
in this randomized lower bound that i
talked about
um so one question is well is there a
more interesting class of functions for
which
there's a quantum speed up you know some
classic function that actually appears
in practice or other people care about
uh another interesting question that i
didn't talk about at all
because i was considering this high
dimensional setting when n was very
large but
let's think about the setting where n is
not very large and let's think about the
setting where n is actually kind of
small
compared to gr or epsilon so that means
you want a very precise estimate
then you're not going to use gradient
descent you would rather use the other
type of algorithm
you know this ellipsoid algorithm type
of algorithm which has complexity
essentially linear in
n and there the interesting question is
what's the best
quantum algorithm for that setting and
all we can say right now is that
there's a lower bound of root n but
there's a gap between this root and an n
and this lower bound of root n was also
only recently shown in this paper of
van appledorn gillian gribbling the wolf
and also in an independent paper of
chakrabarthy
childs lee and wu from from last year
and and in a more open ended
direction you can ask well what about
other natural settings and
convex optimization you know like what
about minimizing smooth functions right
there was a question earlier about like
what about nestraf's accelerated
momentum
method um that's the optimal algorithm
for
the setting of smooth convex function
optimization can you can you do any
better than
classical algorithms in that setting
in that specific setting actually it
turns out the answer is no and we can
we can show this and we have written
this up and it should
show it up here at some point on the
archive but but you can
ask many questions like this right you
know what if i assume something else
about the
function or or you can even go out of
the setting of convex optimization and
go to non-convex optimization it's very
hard to prove stuff there but
i'm sure there's tons of interesting
questions there but can you get quantum
speed ups
for yeah optimization problems
all right yeah so let me let me stop
there thanks
thank you robin it was a very clear talk
so now we have uh plenty of time for
questions
if you have a question please type in q
a
chat or speak up
so i i have a question about uh
you say that um like you
you explain what is the family of
functions that you work with and
i guess this k is roughly like something
like order
n but not quite m
or something no no it's a little it's a
little worse than that
um so for the very specific
family of functions that i showed on the
quantum
multiplied we need n to
be like k cubed so there's a cubic gap
between the dimension and the number of
vectors
but we also present an important
construction in our paper that's much
more complicated
that gets k to be roughly
sorry n to be roughly k squared
and that's also kind of related to the
second question if you could get the
dimension and k to match
then we would also we would also resolve
this more dimensional question
yeah that's true we're not able to we're
kind of stuck
and and you said that so you have two
different uh lower bounds
proofs one is with k square and is with
kq
that's right the the the worst
uses the function that i that i talked
about so so that it's worse only in the
sense that the dimension required for
establishing the lower bound is larger
like it's still proving the same lower
bound of you know one over epsilon
squared
but the the one that's worse uses this
kind of intuitive function that i talked
about on the previous slide which is
it's kind of
easy to see how we went from the
randomized the previous function to this
function
the one the the more complicated
function that gets the better dependence
on dimension
is uh yeah once it's a crazy complicated
function but it appears in
a classical lower bound so so people
have studied the complexity of gradient
descent
in the classical randomized setting but
with
parallel queries to the oracle so now
what happens is in every round you can
make polynomially many queries to the
oracle
and you're only counting the number of
rounds needed and
so this is a much harder setting to
prove lower bounds and
because you're just counting the number
of rounds and you can make many queries
in the first
in each round and for proving lower bars
in that setting so there are better
algorithms known in that setting you
don't you can improve on gradient
descent
but in that setting people have
developed
a very hard class of functions to use
for proving these lower bounds
and that's the class we have to borrow
to make our better lower bound but
that's kind of yeah much more
much more painful so if you just care
about the one or epsilon squared lower
bound you you don't need to you don't
need to read that
that part of our paper so it's kind of
separated out
into first easy lower bound and then the
then the hardware doorbell
but in both both of these cases the the
truth technique that you use is this
hybrid method which was originally used
for uh proving the automotive power
search
yeah yeah the quantum part is identical
in both
like in fact there's a way to do the
very black box way where
all that's done is we just need to
establish certain properties of this
class of functions and
plug into our quantum proof and the same
for either class it's just that
this family of functions is pretty
complicated and the properties that
needs to be established are more
complicated
so does the classical one also use
hybrid method
for the original function that you
showed
no well because um
you see classically like the way you
would argue this is you would just
condition on events right you so you
know
i'm saying that you know you do
something and with very high probability
one minus one or poly in
the you only learn one let's say one bit
of information then you'll say like what
in that one or poly enchants where you
learn more than one bit we just
like up whatever abort or whatever let's
say the classical algorithm just wins
and we'll just condition on that
happening but like you're conditioning
on a very unlikely event
you're on a very likely event so even at
the end of the day most likely you
haven't conditioned anything and
so you use this style of argument
classically which makes the classical
algorithm very
straightforward um but
yeah maybe you can think of the hybrid
argument as some kind of quantum way of
doing this
um
i am i'm not sure how much
you would be like uh i mean you said
it's a preliminary word but but if you
can say a little bit more about
uh this you said that you have something
uh
which is a follow-up work to this and
it's about uh
optimizing like smooth functions that
that would uh
allow nesteros accelerated method and
you see that you show that
like in in that generality you cannot
get it want to speed up
is that the the thing that you are you
said
that's right that's right so the
thing we're able to prove is um okay so
what's the
what's the smooth setting so actually
there's depending on what kind of
mimic on the function there's infinitely
many different smooth settings
um the basic one is you would have that
the
instead of assuming that the function is
lip sheds you'll assume the gradient of
the function is elections
so this we can call like the i don't
know
p equal to one setting but then you
could also assume that like the
you know the first p derivatives
basically ellipses that you can stop
whatever you want
and for each value of p there's a
different optimal classical algorithm
for p equal to one where you assume just
the gradient is lipschitz the optimal
algorithm is the semester of
uh accelerated gradient descent then
for for p equal to two it's it's
something else i
forget what it's called maybe it's
called accelerated
taylor descent um or where for p equal
to three there's a different algorithm
basically there's a recipe for
constructing these algorithms
and for all p you can show that this
family of algorithms is optimal
and the complexity basically goes like
you know it's like one over epsilon to
some power
and the power is a function of p
and the power is something like two over
three p plus one or something
um and what you can show is um
classically at least among deterministic
algorithms
this family of albums is optimal uh so
until our work it was actually not known
that
it was that even for randomized
algorithms the complexity was not known
so in this in this follow-up work that's
still not available yet
we show that for both randomized and
quantum algorithms and for every value
of p
the deterministic algorithm is actually
optimal so there's no quantum speed up
in fact there's no randomized speed up
either
for all values of p so it's a
yeah not only does it establish that
this accelerated gradient descent of
nest
is optimal but like the full family is
actually optimal plan
both classically and quantumly um
yeah so in that case in that result
we're actually able to prove a new
result even classically because the
randomized lower bound was not known
and for any value of e was it known for
like it was fun or even not for that
no
okay no it was known for it was known
that nastra was accelerating this
sentence optimal
classically even for randomized
algorithms that's right i think that was
known
but the higher value versions were not
they were not known
even classically and yeah the next thing
is our construction just kind of gives
it to you for
all p for both classical and quantum
and yes somehow thinking about quantum
forces you to try certain kinds of proof
strategies
it's like you're trying to prove this if
you're trying to grow the randomized
lower bound you would have far
more proof strategies at your disposal
and because we're doing quantum and we
only know one proof strategy which is
this hybrid argument
we had to find a family of functions
that makes that happen but then once we
found that then it just just worked
and gives you a classical auburn for
free so this is one of those cases where
you know having fewer options is better
very nice it's one way one more example
than like classical computer science can
benefit
right i mean although you can yeah you
can take our construction and like
remove all the hybrid method stuff like
once you've
found the family of functions then you
don't need to talk about quantum anymore
it was just that the motivation to find
this exact all of these properties
this we have like a list of three
properties that need to be satisfied
that was because our hands were hybrid
so would it extend also
straightforwardly to
the more general projected gradient
descent to any kinds of convex
constraints um
yeah this i'm not totally sure
yeah if you have different uh convex if
your
convex set is not the not not a ball of
some radius
yeah our lower bounds are pretty
specific to this setting
and i suspect they yeah i'm not sure
actually they may not hold
in fact the optimal algorithms in these
other settings might also not be
the same optimal algorithms in this
setting
yeah that's a good question i i have to
think about it some more but but
isn't the projector gradient descent
also optimally with
in the general setup with convex
constraint
um is that
is that right
i mean without smoothness and strong
complexity and so on so forth where you
can do acceleration
um yeah i'm not not actually sure if if
projected gradient descent is optimal
even for other other things other than
balls like like
if i had like the unit l infinity ball
or something would you still use
projected gradient descent or would you
use a different algorithm
right i would say that in the interest
of time and
keeping up the schedule let's maybe take
this discussion offline
and let's thank romy once again for this
very nice talk
and now it's time